This is FRESH AIR I'm Terry Gross the song. Uptown funk by Mark Ronson was
one of the biggest hits of the year. Today we hear from Ronson as we continue our series
of some of our favorite interviews of the
year. Later we'll feature my interview with Izzy's Ansari and Alan Yang
co-creators of the Netflix comedy series master of none.
Uptown funk is featured on Mark Ronson album uptown special but the lead vocal
is by Bruno Mars. Who co-wrote the song Roth and his musician
producer and D.J. he's put out four albums under his own name and they all feature
other
artists singing the songs he co-wrote and produced.
Bronson's production work on the Amy Winehouse album Back To
Black helped to make international hits out of her songs rehab and you know
I'm no good. Mark Ronson grew up in the music world His stepfather is
Mick Jones the co-founder of the band Foreigner. He was born in London but his family
moved to New York when he was eight. He's now a much sought after
producer and is done recordings with Adele Paul McCartney Ghostface Killah and
Duran
Duran I spoke with Ronson in April just after uptown funk ended
its fourteen week run at the top of the Billboard Hot one
hundred doing.
Much
like this but I'm
afraid that.
It was
pretty clear from the Spider
Man it's writing about him
as. You
know that and break
it down to see how little you care to see how little
you
don't
even know
who to believe
but just
want
to
just
wait a minute. That's Bruno Mars uptown funk produced by my guest Mark Ronson
Mark Ronson welcome to FRESH AIR. What a great track.
Thank you you said that that started as a jam but it's so heavy with hooks and it's
so kind of produced and filled with references to other recordings so it seems so not like a jam.
It's
yeah where it came from an initial burst of it did come out of
a jam a bluenose studio you know he's playing
drums and Jeff Bhasker co-produced the wreck with us and since I
was playing bass and I think that that spirit or at least the rock of most of maybe
that is in there and then yeah like along the way you fine tune it because you're thinking like OK we need to know
turns into a song and
then also when you're doing something that doesn't sound like anything else on the radio at the time
you almost need to like I include it to make sure it gets or you know you have to put these hooks in it
you know you got to make sure you got all that candy in it to get through the
gate. What does it mean to be a producer. I think a lot of people don't really
know what does it mean for you to be a preemie like your real hands
on producer So what does it mean when you're producing so. Thanks.
I think you know for me whatever I need to slot
into to make that music. The best it can be or help the artists who
have I'm working with achieve whatever vision they have in their head for a song so sometimes if
I'm
working with a rapper like those Face Killer onas producing usually means in
hip hop that you make the music you make
the beat and you give it to them and they write the rhymes. Then you know the other more traditional role of
the producer and like the kind of Quincy Jones sense is kind of part arranger if
you're coming up with these you hear these songs are quite bare bones and you dream out well what's
the band doing what's the rhythm section doing what's the guitar strings
pianos that sort of thing. It's almost like a little tool box you just pick up a little bit of
whatever the ones you think are appropriate and you try and you know combine them and then you bring in other people
that are great for the things you're not so good at
so when I was working with Amy Winehouse on back to black you know she had all these
beautiful songs credibly well written and just her on the acoustic
nylon string guitar and she played them for me and then I would kind of drum up my idea
of what I thought make a demo is what I thought the jump should be doing the guitar is
like quite a crude dam and then I play it for her
and she liked it would run with it and then eventually got it that kings into
record and that was
that. We mentioned Amy Winehouse. So let's talk about
the huge hit album that you had with her back to black. I know
you produced most but not all the tracks on that album you produced you know I'm no
good right.
Yeah good let's hear that one and I'm choosing that because it's a great recording and also
the
horns stand out so well on it and that what's all your doing getting the death Kings
to perform with her. So why don't we hear that and then we'll talk about
it so this is the late in the White House the song is you know I'm no good and
that's from her album Back To Black which was largely produced by. Mike asked Mark
Ronson
to
get
out
why one area
where
our bank
where out
out
why and what
our hair
out out out out
out
there
saying with the late Amy Winehouse her song you know I'm no
good at
track was produced by my guest Mark Ronson who produced most of that
album Back To Black which was a huge a huge hit.
So the way you were describing it it sounds like she played you maybe a demo of
the song. What did you hear in your mind and how did
you put that together for what became the final
recording on this song was really one of the best examples of one of the songs that
the debt. Kings you know musicians who play on this stuff really brought to life because of
the chords in the way me had played the song I had always thought of it almost as like a
kind of Latin like samba What is it. It was
originally.
And that's how I had the demo and I kind of got in and I just told the band I was like here's
my range man I'm not really feeling it so why don't you guys just
like hit on a groove of how you would play this chord chart and Homer
and the German the bass player from the DAT King one of the most incredible rhythm
section probably the most incredible written section I've ever worked with just came out with
that
and it just instantly changed the song and then Dave
guy and Neil came up with that horn line
and that was when I really discovered the magic of the debt kings
and how you know very much like the Wrecking Crew in L.A. And you know the
Funk Brothers like our special group of musicians that really just bring you something that nobody
else does.
I think the baritone saxophone works so well because Amy Winehouse has such a deep
voice and to have an instrument that's going to be way beneath her. It
just even adds more deepness yeah to
the
recording I you know that was the first time that I probably ever used
a baritone sax and it's certainly the texture that you know it's all over the record
because it's a nice complement to her
tone. So how did you first heard the dead kings. You must've heard them before deciding
to bring them on for this album.
Yeah I had started to use Dave guy the trumpet player
the credible musician. He came into the studio one day
and they just cut a cover of science will deliver something with Sharon
Jones and I was blown away by how they got that sonic I
mean it was just so much the real deal and had the time Amy and I
was working on demos for Back to Black and I was probably using you know like
whatever computer trick i could they have plugins you know for your computer that make
things sound old whatever it is and.
I played Amy this recording of Sharon Jones and I said like how good it is we should
get these guys to play these damages. Yeah she would say it's
the not if she thought something was really good it was the
not that she said it was the knots and we got the whole band not just the horn section.
So how did you get to work with Amy Winehouse How did you did you approach you. We matched up
with someone else.
Basically there's a good friend of mine who was hit. Yeah
my publishing publishing
company he had asked me was like you know do you know this guy. Amy Winehouse she's in New
York for a day she's kind of meeting people to maybe what was on the second album and I remember
that
about three years before that first regular come out and
I just remember really liking this one song off that cold in my bed and being a little
bit and now I was this you know this young kind of Jewish girl from North London you know the
same thing from a Jewish family from North London this incredible voice and so I said yeah I'll meet her
and you know to be honest I wasn't I got
some big shot I got that point you know I was meeting with anybody that might want to work on music you
know because you never know where chemistry is going to come your break or whatever it is so she came to
my studio one day
and I was on my sis treat my son canal and downtown New York and we hung
out talked about music you know she was so magnetic
and. I guess our energy I just instantly like Sarah and I wanted
to impress her basically like I wanted to have a piece of music that would make
her feel like wow I want to work with this guy you know for lack of
better words and so I said why don't
you go home back to the hotel and I work on something tonight and see you
know come back tomorrow and play your little piece of music and see if you're into it so she would
play me all this stuff in the Shangri-La Zidan of the sixty's girl group that she
was into and I was kind of inspired
and she came back and I had the next more. I mean the
piano chords for Back to Black and the kind of the skeleton beat with the tambourine and
I just put a bunch of cheap reverb on it because I thought like that's what that sound supposed to be like
and she really dug it and that's how we ended up. She ended up staying in New York
another week so we you know the rest of the songs that she
had. What I had for
her for you for you and she had the hit of rehab knowing that she really did
have drug and alcohol problems that that rehab really was an issue in
her life.
I guess because at the point that I met her shoes pretty much so you know
the most together. She had been maybe like in years so it
was strange that everyone was telling me these stories like you know you I can today you know I have good
luck like I said she's been working on this record for three years about.
And I just had no idea what I was talking about because she came into new you know she had these
songs she seemed to be creatively on fire she
wrote back to black in rehab while we were there in the studio and you know kind of a matter of
hours and. So yeah so she was good so when she was telling
me this story about rehab. We're actually walking down the street
and she's saying you know those time a couple years ago I was in this
dark place and my family came over and some friends and they tried to make me go to rehab and
I was like no no no and she put up my hand and I just thought
like that's such a catchy kind of turn of phrase and it
would you know should we go back and just maybe do you want to try to write a song with that because it just
instantly sounded like a hook to me. So it's very much sounded like something
that happened in her life and she kind of moved past so there was never any kind of weird
like yes if she was
like if she had terrible problems and was drinking every day in Syria there's no way I
would have said like oh that's a great idea for a song but because it felt like something that she kind of
you know
just overcome. Didn't seem that
INS in like a bad idea.
When we hear a little bit of that Mrs Amy Winehouse and the track is rehab. It's produced by my
guest Mark
Ronson Taco Bell goes out rehab. They
go
away
the
money I
made
with
the
album So Mark
you come from a a really musical family your stepfather is Mick
Jones who was who is the guitarist in the band Foreigner and wrote one of their biggest hits
I want to know what love is so let's just hear a few seconds of that song to refresh
people's
memory banks
gone
back
to
the top again.
That's foreigner a song written by my guest Mark Ronson stepfather Mick
Jones So how old were you when that song was
released I think that was about maybe ten years old you know that.
He met my mom when I was about seven and then we moved to New York. We live in London at
the time she got married to him and then he wrote that song for
her so it's kind of amazing I mean my wife is always like I
don't write lyrics so I couldn't really technically write a song for anyone I could write a very
nice instrumental so she always gives me a hard time because it's just such a
ridiculously impossible standard to live up to that your stepdad wrote that song for your mom
but
yeah you can understand how in comprehensible it is to me to have parents
where your stepfather wrote a song for your mother
that becomes this
like huge international hit. I can't grasp what that would be like.
Did you like the track when you were ten.
Yeah I think I did I loved it then I think I love it now you know I
really love something about being around the recording studios you know like
those days and
eighty's they would be like in the studio to a four five six in the morning walk on the songs
and sometimes I'd be allowed to be hanging out in the studio which I just love kind of like being in the room
with these big recording Das was all these like buttons and knobs and watching the
guys use them or
sometimes he'd come home you know I was getting up to go first to school in
the
morning he'd be coming home at the same time and I'd he'd play me like the most recent mix
of the song from the studio and asked for my input and I don't remember when it happened but he would
always tell me that I'd be like you know my little English schoolboy voice like well I remember that the
bass was turned up slightly more on the mic from last week and I thought that was good old whatever.
Like there was some little things in there. He said that he came to like really enjoy my opinion
or at least like my little comments on the song so I was kind of destined to probably be
a studio rat.
What has been the impact for you on your life and your career of having a really
big hit again. Uptown
funk. You know it's weird it's it hasn't really
changed my life in any kind of way that I
can measure I mean it's it's obviously
such insane the amazing thing you know none of my
other records I've ever had before
even approaching to the top one hundred you know like there's songs like Valerie and bang bang bang
that I was so proud of and you know the level of success that they had if they were little cult
hits meant that you know I could sell out Webster Hall or Williamsburg musical or that our race here in
L.A. like that was having made it to me so does thought of having a number one song and my own
career like never
even registered and the music is kind of
a it's like a finicky industry to be in of course like tastes change
your one minute you know you know I've been through it quite a few times like on both sides of
it and I guess the best thing about having a successful record like
this is like I know I'm at least another five years before everyone to
like you know the haters start to come out again and that's really what it's like every time you have
one of these years sort of year leases renewed another five years and that's
kind of great for me because it's all I really want to be doing so at this point is
making records and getting to work with artists I think are
exciting. Well Mark Ronson it's been great to talk with you thank you so much and congratulations.
Thank you for having me thank
you my interview with Mark Ronson was recorded in April his single uptown
funk featuring Bruno Mars was one of this year's biggest hits.